[Musique]
au revoir les enfants bon sport le gros
nous avons failli être en retard ce soir
vous savez pourquoi parce que nous avons
fait une rencontre
'le taux de non qu'ils se trouvent dans
ce pub avons entendu des cris déchirants
du haut de notre nuage
c'était ce pauvre petit philibert qui
appelait par ce qu'ils font mais oui
descend vite le mettre au chaud chez
nicolas et pimprenelle nounours et ne
traîne pas trop car tu sais que ce soir
nous partons en voyage
d'accord pas trop vieux petit fils
bieber tu vas avoir bien chaud hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop au cou
ben ça y est ils repartent en voyage oui
mais nous reviendrons très vite
et pendant que je ne suis pas là je vous
confie mon petit ami philippe qu'est ce
que c'est ce qu'annonce regarde bien les
petits as
[Musique]
c'est un joli petit ami qu'il jolie robe
steak au figra
bien sûr il avait froid dehors il pleut
re le jury délibère hausse quel alain
gentil on va lui mettre un peu pareil
tant qu'il est chaud depuis
et puis on lui doit des têtes bonnes
choses à manger et puis on s'occupera
bien lui en d'une once ya pas de
celui-là au nom de leurs provinces
savoir qu'il ait pas de ta famille
nicolas tu es un garnement jardin c'est
très gentil les ans on
je suis tranquille vous vous occuperez
très bien et maintenant on le pose dans
son petit pas dû pour faire d'autre avec
un petit peu de taille là comme ça
allons c'est dodo petit fils et père et
un à côté de notre lit l'espagne ans
mais oui le zoo on voulait vous me faire
un grand plus les nerfs vous allez vous
coucher bien sagement tout de suite en
ivanhoé ben voilà
[Musique]
et vous allez me promettre d'aller très
vite et très sagement on lit chaque soir
catherine ward
oui mais mais toi tu va nous promettre
que tu reviens bientôt avec les petits
marchands de 5 ceux promis sur la tête
de ma chanson est une demande aux petits
marchands de sable de nous chanter sa
chanson musique chants seront maestro
fuse je suis la marchande stable la
journée est finie il faut être
raisonnable
c'est le moment d'aller au lit
tous les jours sur mon nuage
nous nous revient avec moi et nous
partons en voyage
âge dans le ciel par dessus les toits
[Musique]
je n'ai pas d'autre bagages qu'un petit
pot en chanter et du haut de mon nuage
je serai
mon stable doré
ce que vous chantez bien patron bon oeil
un tout le petit
en route fidèle compagnon à bientôt tous
nos petits et grands amis bonne nuit à
bientôt
bagdadi
[Musique]
oh